did you ever hear people say well Jesus
he could be depicted as black or he
could be depicted as Chinese or he could
be his name and I said I even see this
in Catholic institutions it drives me
crazy because I think the whole point is
that the guy is Incarnate right so
people stop being a Christian Theologian
that would seem to be the point if he
takes a specific bodily form and
depicting him as a random bodily form
seems to defeat the purpose yes because
otherwise may as well just not have him
take bodily form yes and then he could
be everything it's like the increase
that's what God is so yes I was talking
to a Catholic friend of mine and he said
I don't mind when people depict Jesus as
any race or anything she's probably like
an American father-in-law he's probably
a short-sworthy Jewish guy I mean I
think the Middle East I think he looks
like the guy on the Shroud of Turin
because I think this rather terrain is
legit but it's like the guy in the
Shroud of Turin looks like a Jewish guy
he doesn't look like a Native American
doesn't look like an Eskimo doesn't look
like a Nordic a Nordic yeah right that's
right it's not German yeah he's not
German yeah